ça va être une reprise progressive déjà
moi je n'ai pas souhaité rouvrir les
maternelle petite section
parce que là le protocole sanitaire est
complètement ahurissant compréhensible
mais à gruissan pour mettre en oeuvre
pour en prendre un exemple toutes les
petites caisses de jouer il fallait
désinfecter tous les jouets les uns
après les autres et les feutres légaux
donc là j'ai dit stop on n'ouvre pas
maintenant on verra un peu plus tard
plus tard et donc la reprise devrait se
faire progressivement à partir du lundi
18 sur le principe de 15 enfants maximum
par classe
donc il y aura des deux groupes le lundi
le mardi et deux autres groupes le jeudi
et le vendredi
ça va s'échelonner je pense qu'à partir
du 25 mai je pense qu'on pourra
accueillir plus d'enfants